this was my last gig
if it hasn't happened by now, it will take a miracle
miracles happen
what happened?
electricity flicked off all over the world
cheese
ellie bought you a present
wow
all my troubles seem so far away
now it looks as though they're here to stay
oh, I believe in yesterday
oh my
when did you write that?
I didn't write it, Paul McCartney wrote it
the beatles
who?
John, Paul, George and Ringo, the Beatles
no
stop it
yesterday, it's one of the greatest songs ever written
well, it's not Coldplay, it's not Fix You
do you genuinely not know who the Beatles are?
genuinely
then I'm in a really, really, really complicated situation
when I find myself in times of trouble
mother mary comes to me
sorry, I'm just listening to Jack's new song
What's this one called?
Leave it be
Let it be
Well, rock on Jack
Oh yeah I'll, tell you something
I wanna hold your hand
Hi, we should talk
see, we pay, and you write songs
and then, you make a ton of money
and then we take most of it
the one, the only, Jack Malley
We would like you to write something, right now
something in the way she moves
No ones ever written this many great songs
how do you do it?
tracks me like no other lover
sometimes it feels like someone else has written all the songs
I've been waiting half my life for you to wake up and love me
but I'm a school teacher, and you, are the world's greatest singer/songwriter
I'm not
Except for that you are
It's going to be the greatest album of all time
I've got two men who claim that the songs are theirs
let's see how this plays out, shall we?
There's something you should know
Please make some noise for Mr. Jack Malley
Let me just give you this advice
song title: hey dude
hey dude, are you sure?
hey dude
it's so much better
dudey, dudey, dudey